this isn't the Welcome people expect
when arriving to check-in at Hong Kong
Airport for the second time in three
weeks anti-government protesters tried
to block access to one of the busiest
terminals in the world in some areas
they succeeded confusing and worrying
travelers and we cannot go back to the
place where you wanted to go people are
afraid because of what's happening here
a court orders in place designed to
prevent protesters coming anywhere near
here it clearly didn't work that legal
action was taken after their last raid
on the airport which saw people camp
inside the terminal for several days
Hong Kong Airport is very important to
the economy we chose here to try to
paralyze it and make our point instead
of randomly picking a street to occupy
it's much better to come here this time
the sight of the police moving in was
enough to force a retreat for most those
not quick enough were arrested in the
end the protesters stay at the airport
was a relatively brief one but again
they prove they can strike at what they
say is a soft target before the police
moved in to retake the area still it
would be a long time before transport
began to return to normal meaning long
walks for many travelers the
demonstrators may have moved on but they
weren't done seemingly frustrated by the
closure of a nearby train station they
vented their anger leaving it in
disarray as night falls the protesters
fan out to different locations and the
police don't seem to be able to match
the agility of those that trying to
chase
and when it's time for a police retreat
loitering protesters and many people
living in areas where some of the
violence has taken place find their
voices again as the officers leave
they're not cheered as keepers of the
peace instead jeered as the enemy and
symbols of a system many here are trying
to change Wayne hey al-jazeera Hong Kong